bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france alors ce plan de
relance est là finalement donc été
adoptée avec malgré les réserves à
ambroise et polonaises que s'est il
passé pour ce pour ce déclic lors de ce
sommet européen est bien un compromis a
été possible parce que compromis qui a
été négocié par l'allemagne qui a la
présidence de l'union européenne a
permis de diluer
cette application de la conditionnalité
pour la dépense des fonds européens en
rapport avec l'état de droit c'est à
dire que la pologne la hongrie s'estime
gagnant dans cette négociation parce que
évidemment là la conditionnalité
juridique est toujours là mais sa mise
en oeuvre sera extrêmement difficile
parce qu'il ya des barrières des délais
notamment avec un passage avec la cour
de justice européenne qui va qui sans
doute permettra la mise en oeuvre de
cette conditionnalité qu'il sera très
difficile donc mais cela ne résout pas
en fait les désaccords fondamentaux sur
la finalité du projet européen
parce que derrière ces discussions
juridiques se cache en fait des des
fractures beaucoup plus profonde entre
états membres sur le devenir de l'union
européenne par rapport à cette cata de
droit c'est à dire d'un côté des
gouvernements qui met en avant un projet
européen qui en fait ne descend pas
l'europe en tant que tel mais la
démocratie libérale et multiculturaliste
qui est plutôt d'inspiration d'ailleurs
américaine dans l'espace euro atlantique
depuis la seconde guerre mondiale et
puis il est
les anciens états membres les anciens
états membres du bloc communiste qui
sont devenus qui sont devenus états
membres de l'union européenne et qui ont
une défense plus civilisationnel de
l'europe et qui considèrent que en fait
cette union européenne doit défendre
avant tout l'europe comme une entité
plus civilisationnel et non pas des
normes d'état de droit qui sont plus
liés à des normes de gouvernance de la
démocratie libérale les
multiculturalistes multiculturaliste cc
question n'est pas réglée on verra à
l'usagé lors des différents comment ces
mécanismes de disputes pourront mettre
pourront être mises en oeuvre mais ce
sera assez difficile et les disputes
vont rester l'union européenne a pris
l'habitude on l'a vu plusieurs fois par
le passé justement de conditionnel de
poser des conditions justement à une
aide notamment envers les pays du sud se
sont compromis qui a été trouvé lors de
ce sommet à bruxelles
est ce que c'est un tournant historique
est ce qu'on peut considérer que c'est
un tournant historique
non je ne pense pas puisque c'est un peu
comme tous les compromis européen ils
sont temporaires précaire et c'est un
compromis institutionnel et juridique et
ça ne résout pas la question de fond sur
les sur le modèle européen les finalités
européenne et donc il y aura toujours
dispute entre les gouvernements des pays
de l'union européenne principalement
aujourd'hui l'allemagne la france qui
défendent la démocratie libérale et puis
les pays d'europe centrale comme la
polonais allons à la hongrie qui ne
veulent pas que les fonds soient
conditionnées par rapport à des normes
des normes de gouvernance et en
particulier le rôle qu'on leur impose
par exemple une défense accrue des
minorités alors qu'il défend de la
nation chrétienne avec moins
d'immigration la gestion des frontières
aussi les questions de plus juridique
sur l'état de droit par exemple
mais les modèles d'enseignement par
exemple les universités qui s'implantent
en hongrie par exemple l'université
soros a t'elle le droit de de tout
enseigner y compris le faire du
prosélytisme libéral je dirais du point
de vue des hongrois alors que les
hongrois veulent garder la maîtrise du
contenu de l'enseignement pour préserver
la nation toutes ces questions vont
rester des questions sensibles et
d'autres questions aussi d'autres
questions qui concernent évidemment ce
plan de relance est 150 ha milliards
d'euros comment et financer ce plan de
relance et puis aussi la question de la
répartition aussi des fonds oui alors
derrière cette répartition il ya une
lutte pour le pouvoir évidemment les
états membres qui seront contributeurs
nets évidemment veulent un contrôle sur
ces fonds qui seront dépensés dans l'est
dans les états membres qui recevront ces
fonds qui ne sont pas contributeurs nets
alors les contributeurs nets seront
surtout l'allemagne les pays-bas mais
aussi la france et donc ils veulent
garder le pouvoir sur ces transferts
financiers
ces transferts financiers aussi ne
seront pas si gigantesque par rapport à
l'année normes crise que nous allons
devoir à laquelle nous allons devoir
faire face à l'avenir avec ces
restrictions à cause du coc vide etc
font aussi il est douteux qui lui
permettront temporairement évidemment de
faire tourner la machine de l'économie
mais cela ne résoudra pas le lait les
fractures qui se sont développées depuis
l'introduction de l'euro entre les pays
du nord et les pays du sud la
désindustrialisation et on voit bien que
le scellé dans la mise en oeuvre de ces
fonds ce sont surtout les pays du nord
qui vont être gagnant parce qu'ils ont
les moyens de mettre en deux mettre en
oeuvre des fonds des fonds pour sauver
leurs économies et les pays du sud
même si temporairement ils pourront
sauver les meubles ne pourront pas se
réunir un dut ce trial ise parce que
tout se sait fonds de relance se produit
dans selon le paradigme de la société
ouverte des économies ouvertes et parce
que l'allemagne et les pays du nord
veulent continuer à exporter vers la
chine vers les états unis et donc les
problèmes après le kovy devons rester
entier merci beaucoup à vous pierre
emmanuel thomas d'avoir répondu en
direct à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes consultant en géopolitique
fondateur du site euros continent